[Music]
my pockets were empty my luck had run
cold City Life and me just don't get on
on the streets and hungry Down and Out
going back to Cobar goodbye to this pwn
I jump the freight I'm heading back my
destination's down that railroad track
I'm going to ride the go line back to
the life I left behind it's not a lot
but I know it's mine I'm heading back on
down the cob
line going back the MLT is a business
operated for the community we operate in
the hospitality industry after assets
maintained and overheads are met the MLT
returns uh profits to the community for
Community projects and in the last three
years has has been over a million doll
cash a friendly local town with great
brown trout fishing about 100 m just
down the road from the local radio
station the East sou and gallery hosts
one of the most intriguing and eclectic
um collections of Art in the southern
region and you'll go away um amazed
guarantee you
[Applause]
[Music]
everyone I just want to tell you Gore is
the place to go it's amazing home of
country music home of gold guitars
friendliest people settle down have a
holiday or just play country music
woohoo I'm on the mother low I jump the
freight I'm heading back my
destination's down that railroad track
I'm going to ride the Cobar line back to
the life but I left behind well it's not
a lot but it's all mine I'm going to
ride the Cobar line back to the line
that I left behind well it's not a lot
but I know it's mine I'm going back on
down the
C so Sergeant Dan why have you spent so
long in
[Music]
Gore